yo
puede girar en círculos
también
hace unos ruidos geniales
tratar de acercarlo
la gente
ok y uno decente
está hecho de un montón de cosas que
tienes en la casa como un reloj con
alarma una secadora de cabello una
cafetera muchas cosas que usas todos los
días
un micrófono esto de abajo con una
cafetera
tiene tapas de botellas otras partes de
la botella y tiene parte de mi secadora
de cabello también tiene una bocina de
un reloj de alarma
ok cuando cuando dejan de hacerlo una
dos tres mil
hola
tiene muchas cosas interesantes de
ciencias y matemáticas
que aún no sé tengo que aprender
creo que es muy divertido
lo que más me gusta de si bot
probablemente es todo
y yo no